on allegra strassen's resignation she
resigned today she looked broken as she
did it how did you feel
when you watched that statement and
watched what she said heard what she
said
and doesn't it lead to your leadership
being questioned if others are taking
responsibility for things that happen in
this place instead of you taking
responsibility and to the scientists
people are going to feel pretty flat
today listening to this press conference
they were told to get their jobs to get
their boosters that we would have an
irreversible path out of lockdown that
life would continue winter comes we are
now being told that we have to live with
restrictions again is this just the
reality of living with covid so this
this is not just another year this is
happening but this is our lives now for
years to come i think people will be
worried about that thank you
so just for beth first on your first
point look yeah i repeat what i said to
to laura i think that allegra has been
an outstanding uh spokesperson for
uh for the government for cop uh she did
she did an extraordinary job and i'm i'm
very very sorry to to lose her on your
point about responsibility i didn't just
take responsibility for things that
happened in this uh in this in this
building uh i take response to
everything that happens in this in this
government and i've made i've made that
clear throughout the pandemic
on the
question about
where we are now what that means for the
future
this virus has mutated a lot quickly
and
that is sort of what you'd expect at
this stage that you start to see more
mutations
this one's got a lot more than anyone
thought would arrive that quickly
and that's what's caused so many
concerns about it spreading very fast
the good news is that so far it looks as
though when you get very high antibody
levels with the booster vaccine it's
definitely having some effect against it
in the laboratory studies we need to
watch and see what happens over the next
few weeks as we get more data on that so
the boosters remain incredibly important
as a way of increasing immunity
what we're on is a road from
pandemic to endemic where this becomes a
more sort of regular infection like flu
or something over time but we're in a
sort of bumpy transition for that and
that's going to be difficult and it is
difficult now and there are special
measures that need to happen now to try
and reduce the spread it doesn't mean
this is what happens in perpetuity
you would expect that over time this
becomes a virus which then has
peaks every year just in the way that
flu does perhaps
but it wouldn't be endlessly having
new variants that always escape escape
vaccines to some extent you would also
expect that the vaccine will need to
change over time just as the flu vaccine
changes year on year and you get a
slightly different one because the thing
continues to evolve a bit
so i think this is a
surprise change that's happened it's a
big one and yes it's going to make
everyone feel a bit sort of deflated
about it but there are things that can
be done i think the vaccines are going
to hold up to some extent here and i
think probably boosters will really push
that to a level that's going to be
important we need to test that and find
out
and i don't think it's a harbinger of
what happens here after we may see we
will see more variants
and they will always cause some sort of
challenge but that challenge is the same
sort of challenge that you're going to
see year on year with other things as
well
over time
can i just add to that because i mean i
obviously completely agree
um
we're in a transition period from a
point uh when we when the pandemic first
hit
in 2020 where we had to rely entirely on
social measures and had no medical
countermeasures
we will get to a stage where we have
multiple countermeasures probably lots
of different types of vaccines
antivirals we currently don't a whole
variety of other roads which is the way
we have dealt now
with very many infectious diseases we're
in that midpoint
we are immeasurably better off now than
we were with the vaccines we've got with
drugs with better hospital treatments a
whole bunch of things that are so much
better than they were
it would be much quicker getting over
this than it would have been if we the
same situation had hit us a year ago but
we shouldn't no point if we said that
there wouldn't be new variants
significant ones potentially and vaccine
escape ones that said that's been said
by almost every i sped every media
outlet that's uh represented here
repeatedly and for good reasons that's
the biological uh inevitability now when
it comes to this particular so in the
long run i think the outlook is good but
i think we have to accept that it's not
it is still a difficult period
and in terms of this particular variant
the question i think is really going to
be
is this held by the current vaccines
with boosters
or are we actually going to have to do a
reformulation of that the viru the
vaccine at least for more vulnerable
people uh and that that is what we will
need to do
over time and it may be actually what we
have is a transition period where the
booster holds it for a bit and that buys
us time and then we can actually get a
specific or
what's called polyvalent vaccine and
that will allow us then to in you know
from later on in this year be able to
respond to it directly so i think we
should in a sense what i think we should
say is i can see why people feel
deflated but this is a kind of setback
this is not a this is not a situation
we're back to square one we are we're
kind of we're having to just deal with
it as we always thought we might have to
you said that you were furious about the
video you saw about the mock press
conference yes
how did you feel when you saw a legacy
i'm sorry i'm sorry because of the
of the
the huge uh
press of of uh meetings so far today i i
haven't been able to uh to see that i'm
of course aware of what uh allegra has
has said and i i i i just repeat what i
what i said i'm i'm very grateful to her
for everything that she's uh that she's
done and
uh i i i wish her uh all the very best
and and and we will certainly miss you
miss her uh here here in government but
i just want to add to uh to what what
chris has said on um this this this
crucial period because
i think that uh there is a there is a
at least of a strong possibility uh that
we will uh discover in the course of the
next few uh days and weeks that
indeed the the combination of
of two jabs and a booster is capable of
holding omicron in
in equilibrium in the way that uh we
want and and then as i said we will be
able uh to move forward and it's always
worth bearing in mind that what we're
doing today uh with plan b is something
that we we set out uh back in september
so this is not a a deviation from uh
what we the position that we thought we
might find ourselves in as as winter
winter set in we always reckon that you
would we'd see a spike in uh in disease
and um
and in infection uh but actually delta
has been remarkably stable uh the
problem uh has been the sudden emergence
of omicron and the real spike
that it's producing and and given the
potential numbers that omicron could
produce we just have to respond uh today
in the in the way that we are